it was another night of gun violence in
cities across america
two men were shot and wounded in a
popular section of washington d.c
known for its restaurants and bars
another three people were shot
late at night in pittsburgh and a police
officer was hurt
this comes as the department of justice
launches a nationwide crackdown on gun
violence
sending prosecutors and federal agents
to washington and several other major
cities
jeff because is traveling with attorney
general merrick garland in chicago
where the police superintendent says
there's been a surge in drive-by
shootings
unseen in decades jeff good morning this
is an ambitious effort by the justice
department
oh yeah the feds are really making a big
push here because
crime is off the charts gun violence
especially
in fact chicago police recovered about 7
000
legal guns that's a 25 percent increase
over last year a lot of those guns
smuggled into this city and then used to
commit crimes
it's a state of emergency pastor
ira akri has been a community leader on
the west side of chicago for
30 years he says gun violence in the
city has been worse than ever
lord i wish to support nobody there was
a time
when you heard of students it would be
young men but now people are getting
gunned down kids on their bicycles
little children dancing on the porch for
their parents
grandparents getting their brains blown
out
chicago is a city awash in illegal guns
and mass shootings
we're sending a message to the gun
traffickers we are going to find you no
matter where you are
the uptick in gun violence here and
across the country
has prompted the justice department to
launch gun strike forces
to five cities teams that will try to
chase
down the illegal weapons before they end
up on the street
in the hours before the attorney general
landed in chicago
18 shot including eight on this party
bus
people are grieving across the city i
know that there was
terrible shootings just a few days ago
and just a few blocks from here and i
know that that has deeply affected the
members of
this very group so this is real life
pastor akri says increased law
enforcement resources alone
isn't enough that's like a drop in the
bucket for to sit back and think that if
we're going to just come here
and have a task force stay around here
that's going to solve it
we need every institution doing
something
yeah what he believes is that to solve
this crime problem in this city
you need to also give people hope give
them opportunity
give them jobs and so that's the message
that he is trying to communicate
also today attorney general merrick
garland
meeting this morning with doj officials
in chicago the ag's hometown
gail they got to figure something out
thank you jeff very much